foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story Child Care pensions and a
prediction of no recession it's a budget
for growth says Jeremy Hunt the
declinists are wrong and the optimists
are right
we we stick to the plan because the plan
is working
a promise of support for working parents
of the youngest children but that will
be delayed and the industry is concerned
about the cost
the sparks flying too over a pension
giveaway to the best paid workers as
labor says the government's expiry date
is coming close
[Applause]
and the public sector workers on their
biggest day of strikes are told their
disputes are down to inflation with no
extra money announced
also tonight the latest Bank in the
firing line over Financial worries as
the stock markets take another huge hit
and America and Russia's relations in a
lamentable State the warning from Moscow
after the ditching of a U.S drone
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening it didn't look
like a pre-election budget but it
certainly started to prepare the path
money to help parents return to work a
pensions giveaway for higher earners and
an attempt to incentivize business to
invest more Jeremy Hunt also had an
improved message over the economy so
it's very far from flying well the
chancellor told MPS that the UK is
expected to avoid recession this year
with forecasts that inflation will fall
to 2.9 percent by the end of 2023 for
households the energy price guarantee
will continue until June with bills
capped at two and a half thousand pounds
the fuel Duty freeze and the current
five pencil leader cut will be extended
and draft beer Duty has also been frozen
30 hours free child care a week will be
available to working parents in England
with children aged between nine months
and five years but it won't come in
fully until September 2025. the lifetime
allowance the total amount that people
can accumulate in their pensions pot
before paying extra tax is abolished and
the pension's annual tax-free allowance
Will Rise by 50 percent for business a
nine billion pound full expensing scheme
will let firms who invest in I.T plant
or Machinery deduct the cost in full
from their taxable profits well tonight
we'll hear what business makes of that
and also whether these measures will
help get people back into work but our
first report comes from our political
editor Beth Rigby
stepping out
but this a Chancellor still holding the
line
and stick in to the plan
Jeremy Hunt hoping to turn the country's
economic fortunes around in time for the
next general election
today a Chancellor with a spring in his
step
and this was why I report today on a
British economy which is proving the
doubters wrong
[Music]
today the office for Budget
responsibility forecasts that because of
changing International factors and the
measures I take the UK will not now
enter a technical recession this year
we are following the plan and the plan
is working
the economic news he wanted to deliver
but still a way to go today we deliver
the next part of our plan a budget for
growth a much briefed in advance the
main thrust of it getting away in
Workforce back into jobs ineligible
households where all adults are working
at least 16 hours we will introduce 30
hours of free child care not just for
three and four-year-olds but for every
single child over the age of nine months
that child care provision staggered not
coming in fully until 2025 working mums
a portion of the population targeted in
a pre-election Splurge as were the over
50s millions of them leaving the world
of work the chance for offering a mighty
tax break on pension pots to entice some
of them back I will increase the
pension's annual tax-free allowance by
50 percent from forty thousand to sixty
thousand
some have also asked me to increase the
lifetime allowance from its one million
pound limit instead I will go further
and abolish the lifetime allowance
scrap in the limit on the lifetime
pension allowance helping the very rich
and as the corporation tax rate hike
kicks in a kicker for business with a
series of investment incentives worth
billions we will introduce a new policy
of full Capital expensing that means
that every single pound a company
invests in it equipment plant or
Machinery can be deducted in full and
immediately from taxable profits a nod
from the PM this government hopeful it's
enough the declinists are wrong and the
optimists are right and I commend this
statement to the house
a crowd please in Chancellor a budget
backed by the front bench
but with living standards set to full
farther the opposition benches scathing
I hopelessly divided party caught
between a rock of Decline and a hard
place of their own economic recklessness
dressing up stagnation of stability as
their expiry date looms ever closer
and the Lumen election on the minds of
many and through former cabinet
Ministers of recent months concerned we
have arised now in corporation tax but
we then sort of salami slice it a bit
with some Capital allowances to pretend
it's not much of a rise this is not a
good approach to tax policy the best
approach to tax policy is low tax rates
with few exclusions many Tory MPS want
tax cuts right now but this budget was
about laying the groundwork for tax cuts
to come just in time for the next
general election the watchwords for this
budget were growing the economy and all
of the big measures were targeted to do
just that this is a chancellor who wants
to prove his doubters wrong but he and
the Prime Minister know all too well
that turn in disillusioned voters into
Believers once again is going to be a
very hard task
families still grappling with the
largest fall in living standards in
modern times might take little comfort
from this budget the road ahead still
Bleak Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster
well today's budget was not presented
like a conventional giveaway but there
will be large sums of money paid out to
key constituencies like businesses which
invest as well as workers with large
pension pots the backdrop to the budget
though is a continued crunch on
household incomes as our economics and
data editor Ed Conway explains
when it comes to the budget one of the
big questions of course is how is the
economy doing let's have a look at some
of the big numbers this is gross
domestic product the rate at which our
national income is increasing or in the
case of 2023 decreasing last time it was
forecast to go down by 1.4 percent look
at how that's changed so bring red bars
on these are the latest forecasts not
down by 1.4 down by 0.2 so no recession
uh says the treasury but it's not
exactly much to write home about it is a
bit stronger next year but look at this
uh in the future a little bit weaker but
the other kind of big picture when it
comes to the economy is looking at
household disposable income this is a
different measure which kind of has
gives you a sense of just how well off
people are feeling or otherwise usually
it's going up this is the measure of
just how well off you're feeling each
year adjusted for inflation going all
the way back to the 1950s and probably
you'll recall last time around the obr
was talking about the worst two years
that we've seen since the 1950s this
time those numbers have been revised but
have a look look at those red bars
it's not by much is it look I'll show
you last time down by a lot this time
well down by quite a lot and actually
draw a line going all the way back and
those are still the worst two years uh
in modern records so that's not
necessarily encouraging but a bit better
than it was last time the government is
going to be spending quite a lot of
money here actually more than some
people had expected this shows you the
impact of the budget measures anything
below the line there's money leaving the
exchanga going out into people's pockets
quite a lot for three years then Less in
the future that's after the next
election so no coincidence is there and
if you break it down a lot of this was
what's known as full expensing so
government basically saying to
businesses you're able to write off some
of the money you spend on new plants new
Machinery against your tax bill really
big thing and actually quite a big chunk
of this uh you've got child care that's
quite a lot of money as well about five
billion six billion pounds as well
pensions that's smaller in terms of the
amount of money quite a bit smaller um
but of course quite controversial
because it's only a small number of
people but they are better off who
benefit from that increase in the low
lifetime allowance and some were to
argue that when it comes to investment
which is one of the things the
government wants to increase it's not
necessarily going to go up as much as it
had hoped this was the forecast for
investment last time around were it not
for the measures this is what investment
would have done but have a look after
that Plan full expensing a lot of people
excited about it actually business
investment is lower than it was were it
not for that measure so there are lots
of question marks about this but many
different things to show over it felt
like the most normal budget we've had in
quite some time and the economy looking
a little bit better than it was before
let's get more analysis then on the
Chancellor's budget Ed Conway is with me
now I'll talk to you in just a moment Ed
but first of all let's head to our
political editor Beth Rigby and Beth not
a big conventional tax giveaway today as
we said but a budget still with one eye
on a general election
yeah absolutely Anna and and that eye on
the general election really is focusing
at the moment on the conservative party
trying to rebuild trust with the public
that they can be trusted on the economy
the chancellor going to address his own
MPS tonight telling them there's no path
to success for the conservatives unless
they have a reputation of economic
competence and that was the big message
if you like of today and MPS that I've
spoken to quite liked what they heard
many liked some of the policies around
child care they liked the investment
allowances and they like this sense of a
competent government if you like so I
think it was as Steady As She Goes not a
big bang budget here I do think there
are things in it though that could
backfire on the chancellor when it comes
to that abolishing the lifetime limit on
pensions it only benefits the top
earners only about one percent of the
population labor saying will benefit
from it while labor are now saying that
they will oppose that measure so you
could see some fireworks around that
labor will try and couch this as the
conservative party looking after the
rich and not giving real tax breaks to
work in people and and on that I think
another problem with all of this is that
the freeze to tax allowance says that
Jeremy Hunt announced actually last
November and are kicking in it's going
to drag millions of people into higher
tax bans it's called the fiscal drug
it's when the bans freeze your wages go
up so in the end you end up paying more
tax over the next five years the office
of budget responsibility the fiscal
Watchdog are saying six million people
are going to be affected by that what
does it tell us people are going to feel
a lot poorer for the remainder of the
year and I guess the big question when
the chancellor prepares for tax cuts in
the Autumn statement in the next budget
is it going to be too little too late
the conservatives are still over 20
points behind in the polls
Beth live there in Downing Street thank
you and add lots more on picking of the
budget to come but the backdrop to this
was the public sector workers striking
outside and Market Jitters too they're
not about what Jeremy Hunt had to say
yeah that's right and you know the funny
thing is actually this does feel to some
extent though Beth was saying it feels
like a little bit boring I wonder if
that's because we've become a newer to
these crisis budgets you know this is
actually in a way the first normal
budget that we've had going all the way
back to kind of pre-covered times
because if you think about all of those
crazy fiscal events and then what
happened obviously last last year it was
it was actually a little bit a little
bit bigger in the kind of fiscal terms
than some people were expecting but yeah
it didn't have quite the fireworks the
previous ones what was interesting as
you say Anna is the fireworks seem to be
off stage and not necessarily in a good
way we're used well recently we had a
budget which caused Financial eruptions
uh obviously last year the mini budgets
um markets were going kind of South
during this during the chancellor
statement but not because of anything he
was doing and you can see what's
happened to the ftse 100 we'll show you
a chart on the big screen here just look
at the right hand side there it is
Fallen very sharply indeed today I mean
that's going back the past year okay but
but that fall that we saw today in
particular that kind of horror vertical
line on the right hand side that's even
bigger than when we saw what we saw
after the mini budget is even bigger
than what we saw after the invasion of
Ukraine so we're talking about markets
being worried why are they worried as I
say it's not because of anything the
chancellor has done on the contrary it's
because they're concerned about the
financial system obviously we had the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank in the
U.S and its uh British part as well you
have other banks in the US in trouble
some of some other banks are having runs
as well and now in Switzerland Credit
Suisse very big Investment Bank there
under threat as well they've shared
share prices collapse all sorts of
problems there so when you take a step
back all of the world is reacting to the
fact that interest rates are going
higher and it's causing all sorts of
malfunctions around the financial system
and the worry is that could be
contagious no one knows for sure um a
lot of nervousness out there keeping an
eye certainly closely on that Ed thank
you very much indeed well the chancellor
told MPS that Enterprise was one of his
four priorities for economic growth and
his announcement of tax incentives to
invest in equipment was welcomed by one
firm we spoke to today there are doubts
though over whether enough has been done
to help the youngest companies as our
business correspondent Paul Kelso
explains
in a Life Science and Tech Hub in
Bristol emofaron is working on new
vaccine technology to start up with a
great idea that could help change
medicine and it's not alone this is an
incubator for high risk early stage
Enterprises that need incentives to
survive
they wanted more generous tax breaks of
research the chancellor disappointed
overall I think underwhelming and this
is a really important part of the cash
flow particularly at the minute and a
quite a hard funding environment and
companies finding it quite hard to get
money so this was almost halved in the
Autumn budget and now we've come up
close to not the same as not quite where
we were I don't think they've done
enough to make us competitive say with
the US in in this regard it is risky you
know that a lot of these companies most
of them fail but the potential upscale
is enormous it increases the risk
overall and of something that's already
a very risky asset Club
established Industries need help to
spark growth too this valve manufacturer
will open the spending Taps after the
chancellor announced every penny
invested in Machinery premises in it can
be written off against corporation tax
going up contentiously to 25 percent one
big area for us is to improve our valve
assembly repair overhaul and testing
Arena but that would take a significant
investment I stalled on just to see
what's going to be happening over the
next year and that's something now that
could be facilitated using using the
corporation tux reduction
this budget is an attempt to stimulate
growth and Stave off recession by giving
companies and consumers the confidence
to spend but after the economic trauma
of last year it feels like just the
first step to convincing business that
Britain is back on track
Brewers and beer drinkers will get a
boost with Duty Frozen on pints bought
in pubs with everything else Budweiser
sells faces steep tax rises in August
for the world's biggest Brewer the big
picture matters there is a finite pot of
money and if the UK doesn't have a very
business friendly environment when it
comes to taxation when it comes to the
incentives they're giving business then
other other countries will win out
it's still too soon for the chancellor
to tow success
Paul Kelso Sky News
holy help for child care for the
youngest children is meant to free
parents to return to the workplace but
only if providers can respond one told
us today she wasn't sure the sector had
the energy to battle for funds saying
the government's rate isn't enough it
was a different message from parents
though as Ivor Bennett reports
they're getting ready to celebrate Saint
Patrick's Day at this class for new
parents in their minds though it's the
budget it's delivered a pot of gold I
think it's really really helpful we
would you know it would really make
things easier it would just make
Transition go back to work really easy
as well chats that we're having daily in
our household at the moment how we're
going to structure our finances all of
that kind of compound is this uses is uh
looking good isn't it hello what's your
name but it won't be looking good
immediately the three hours that
Chancellor's offering won't start until
next April and the full 30 hours for all
aged over nine months won't come until
September 2025. UK child care costs are
among the most expensive in the world
with full-time care for a child under
two costing on average 14
000 pounds a year but helping parents
out is one thing for child care
providers there are doubts over whether
Supply will be able to meet demand
good boy and a big jump at this Nursery
in Coventry they're struggling to
balance the books
like others they already provide free
child care to three and four-year-olds
but that comes at a cost current
government subsidies aren't enough it
means manager Claire Richmond may not
even offer the new hours it's less about
hanging on it's more about whether the
sector will support this at all I think
we're tired of being insulted with
funding rates as the years go on that
I'm not sure the sector have got the
energy for yet another battle to try and
save our businesses it seems fruitless
what
[Music]
the government says it will
substantially raise rates for providers
but after years of underfunding the
sector is skeptical
on top of that a rising bills and
falling staff numbers
sector that cares for others
it needs to be cared for itself either
Bennett Sky News Coventry
the chancellor today said that inflation
was the root cause of the public sector
strikes which brought thousands of
workers to Westminster today teachers in
England and civil servants joined Junior
doctors in dispute actually her and I
spoke to some Marching for higher pay
snaking through the streets of the
capital tens of thousands of public
sector workers tried to drown out the
Chancellor's words
[Applause]
a chance may differ but the message is
the same more pay and better conditions
for teachers tube drivers civil servants
and Junior doctors despite this turnout
though they still don't feel heard you
just have to step foot into a school to
notice that it's at its knees and so we
need better pay
kids
to live by myself
as the chancellor addresses the commons
tens of thousands address him their
campaigns so far culminating in the
biggest state of industrial action yet
the Sea of solidarity Phil Trafalgar
Square and featured old and new faces
with far from New problems when I'm
talking about resources I don't mean
like rubbers and rulers because we're
kind of used to not having those things
anyway but it's more about having like
the right support staff for students
frustrations shared across the country
including in Salford where union members
echoed the Rumblings that have built up
for months timing it on budget day was
no coincidence the chancellor reaffirmed
his promise to invest 2 billion pounds
in the nation's schools but his
ambiguity over how it'll be spent and
how these disputes will be resolved if
negotiations aren't happening these
national days of industrial action won't
be a one-off ashnaharanag Sky News in
central London
elsewhere in the news tonight a 29 year
old man has been charged with attempted
murder after a woman was stabbed outside
a Cheltenham Leisure Center last
Thursday Joshua Bowles has also been
charged with actual bodily harm and will
appear at Westminster magistrates court
tomorrow
a funeral has taken place for a 16 year
old who was attacked in a park in
Cheshire last month priyana Jaya
transgender girl was found with fatal
stab wounds a boy and a girl both aged
15 have been charged with her murder
a court in Lahore has ordered a pause to
the operation to arrest former prime
minister Imran Khan following further
unrest he claims the charges against him
are part of a plot to discredit him by
his successor as prime minister
theostrone that went down in the Black
Sea after allegedly being struck by a
Russian jet may never be recovered U.S
officials have said the U.S defense
secretary hit out at Russia demanding
better professionalism from its Air
Force Russian officials have responded
claiming the Drone was in an off-limit
area our U.S correspondent James
Matthews reports
they call it the MQ-9 Reaper drone the
United States says it's surveillance
craft was intercepted in international
airspace by Russian jets that dumped
fuel on it and caused it to crash in the
Black Sea
this hazardous episode is a part of a
pattern
of aggressive and risky and unsafe
actions by Russian pilots in
international airspace
so make no mistake
the United States will continue to fly
and to operate wherever international
law allows
on the day Vladimir Putin welcomed
Syria's president to the Kremlin Moscow
wasn't entertaining the U.S version of
events
controls over the Black Sea before
on this occasion Russia says this Jets
were sent to intercept the Drone but
made no contact
as a result of a Sharp maneuver the MQ-9
drone went into unguided flight with a
loss of altitude and crashed into the
sea I want to emphasize that the Russian
Fighters didn't use their weapons didn't
come into contact with the unmanned
aerial vehicle and they safely returned
to their base
Russia's Ambassador was summoned to the
U.S state Department as Washington
complained of a Brazen violation of
international law
Moscow said it planned to retrieve the
drone's wreckage and the Kremlin
spokesman described its relations with
the United States as deplorable at their
lowest point
the Grim fate of the MQ-9 Reaper further
Dawkins fraught diplomacy
James Matthews Sky News Washington
now if there was a theme to today's
budget it was to help people to work
businesses encouraged to invest and hire
more parents and older workers targeted
to stay in the jobs market so how will
today's message land with the people
it's aimed at are people in politics
correspondent Nick Martin reports now
from Liverpool
so you're returning back and then the
skills are different the workplace is
different and it's quite scary Karen
Tyndall is 62 years old and wants to
work so she's come here to this drop-in
center in Liverpool for help and advice
on how best to do it
the chancellor has announced measures to
get people back to work including those
over 50. so-called return ships and even
skills boot camps Karen says she likes
the sound of it so you would think that
the government are on the right Lines by
saying look yet we we need to do more we
need to get the over 50s skills get back
into work and do some real life I think
it's great but I don't think that people
should be on the minimum wage
so not just any job a good quality
meaningful job absolutely yeah the best
Empower other people
think the best opportunities by being in
that job Britain's tight labor market is
the backdrop Behind these measures with
nearly a fifth of the working age
population in the UK economically
inactive the chancellor needs to make it
easier for women in particular to get
back into work it's brilliant if
Government can put into places
additional support however we're
concerned because it just looks like
it's a package that's been thrown
together there needs to be significant
investment into these women's Economic
Development
this is important because Britain is
actually in the grip of a Workforce
crisis with companies trying to fill
around a million vacancies this isn't
just about people finding jobs this is
the Cornerstone of the government's
ambition to drive the economy but while
much of the government's strategy is
focused on older people it didn't offer
much for the young the 16 to 24 year
olds
Sky Duffy is 17. she's desperate to
learn more and achieve her ambition of
becoming a journalist so you've got a
chance to watch the budget what was your
initial reaction when you when you saw
it it was honestly quite disappointing
because a whole generation was missed
out on the budget you know people my age
are trying to navigate life becoming an
adult you know people are applying for
uni through ucas or trying to get
apprenticeships and I feel like there
was no guidance given to people our age
and there was like no government support
the chancellor is trying to increase
employment but it's not easy
redundancies are up wages are stagnating
and a recession looms McMartin Sky News
Liverpool